[Music]
luanne's with us in iowa city hi luanne
how are you
oh my gosh star struck
me too what's up
okay so here's the thing this is not
really a math problem because the math
is kind of a duh
it's more of an emotional thing so i'm a
nurse
um obviously i have the option to go
travel
for upwards of around five thousand
dollars a week which is about three
thousand dollars more than i made this
week working 72 hours between my two
jobs
um
the concerns are my husband's a little
freaked out by it
because
i would be gone
approximately three to four days a week
in a row because the jobs are
not commutable but within a few hour
drive
[Music]
my mom assists us with our six kids and
is very generous and does it
for
um
basically nothing
um
i think some of his concerns are
that for one we have amazing health
insurance through my jobs they're both
county ran jobs so i have state
insurance state retirement and very very
cheap health insurance
and also my only life insurance even
though i have pursued it
privately is through my job i've just
not been able to get it through my job
because
i had a health issue several years ago
that put us out and that was the one
brick in the wall that sent it all
crumbling and we had to file bankruptcy
but of course i got to keep my massive
student loans um that i think he just
made a documentary about me i watched it
so the question is
how do we make this decision how much
debt have you got
93 000 except for the house the house is
100 so the plan would be you go on the
road for how long and then you come back
home and land a new nourishing cake
in one year i could pay everything
including the house off okay
how old are you
i'm 42 okay and you have six kids three
yeah from three to sixteen
and um we do homeschool a fair amount of
them but my mom is huge in helping with
that okay is she up for this for a year
yes she has been very supportive she
thinks it's silly that i'm working these
crazy hours
drive to des moines for she's the she's
the generation that worked their tail
off yeah okay
right she's like in two and a half hours
you can go to des moines you can work
your three nights and come home and be
home for four days
and
make twice the money three times the
money yeah
our local hospitals have done incentive
pay so it's basically an extra you know
forty dollars an hour which by the time
you figure benefits and stuff that's
essentially what the travel
pay is well the way i would look at it
is this if this was a permanent change i
couldn't sign up for it because of what
it would do to my family
it's not a permanent change it's a
one-year adventure
can we do can we can the kids
mom the husband and you
look at this like i'm gonna do this for
one year
and change our lives i've been praying
yeah we filed bankruptcy yeah and i feel
like god's like here it is yeah
i i had a lady on i had a lady do a
debt-free scream uh just a couple of
months ago that paid off 500 000 in one
year
travel nurse coveted all she did was
work on the road and she paid off she
made a half a million dollars in one
year it was unbeaten
i don't think i can work all of the time
i mean you can't do that you're going
back home you're just doing 370 312's
but uh and getting k and getting a
serious bonus for doing it
i mean
hypothetically you could do 312's come
home and do some more from home
but uh right
that's that's that's asking a lot
yeah i have if everybody can line up on
this relationally it's not just the math
it's the sense of i'm impacting my life
for a short period of time
uh people are deployed for six months or
a year at a time
all the time in the military there's
lots of people who travel for a living
it happens all the time and if you look
at it as a short-term thing for a
long-term gain and everybody's calling
it an adventure do it but if somebody's
going to really squeal then you probably
don't do it this is the ramsey show